à l'écouter contrat chose
alors que s'ouvre la semaine du handicap
à plaisir elle se referme sur montigny
comme chaque année depuis neuf ans la
ville souhaite sensibiliser le jeune
public au handicap
la manifestation s'achève toujours par
un dimanche de mise en pratique d'un
côté l'association handi grain mené par
philippe lumière à la nuit à
l'association ciel et l'association
handicap qui font grimper des à des
personnes valides à être des handicaps
artificiellement tâche était attaché aux
yeux bandés et on a aussi une
démonstration avec les membres de
l'équipe de france par atelier de
l'autre l'association média handicap mis
en place par sébastien brouillard le but
c'était de faire le triathlon de
l'espérance le très pondéré espérons ces
trois défis en situation de handicap
donc les situations de handicap c'est
une situation en fauteuil roulant il
paraît totalement fauteuil roulant a
pris ils doivent lancer de la balle dans
un panier de basket continue
héloïse par exemple s'est essayé au
fauteuil roulant cette jeune et ni
monteyne de 9 ans a incité sa maman à
faire le parcours typique en passant par
la porte c'est pas c'est dur et pour les
personnes est toujours un fauteuil
roulant ça doit être dur c'est bien
bruit plutôt moins puisse un jour se
dire moi j'ai la chance
de pouvoir remarcher d'être en bonne
santé maintenant l'équipe d'une dizaine
de bénévoles à préparer le parcours de
mise en situation de handicap
sous le regard attentif de noémie lenoir
marraine d'honneur de l'association les
plus grandes difficultés c'est en
fauteuil roulant donc quand on fait le
défi là bas d'ouvrir une porte de passer
un trottoir ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est bien parce que cette association
est aujourd'hui ça permet vraiment de
voir ce que les handicapés vivent tous
les jours il ya des évolutions de
mentalité il faut tout temps faire
mettre en place des actions pour que ça
se pérennise
en 2013 la semaine du handicap de
montigny fêtera ses 10 ans de quoi
dresser un bilan sur les actions menées
autour du handicap